welcome to exploring computing
today's video is digital music
part four digital data versus analog
world
this week we've looked at a number of
differences between what happens in the
computer
and what we're used to in real life so
the first difference that we saw was
that
we're used to using decimal numbers but
the computers use binary numbers
but the second difference is the
difference between analog
and digital now we went over the
difference between binary and decimal
first
and the concept of binary numbers really
does pervade computing
we see this when we're out trying to
purchase a phone and we see we've got
choices of
64 128 256 or 512.
we've seen this as we've discussed our
digital images where we see that colors
come in 24-bit color or
32-bit color and with our sounds where
we have 16-bit
samples and so i covered it first
because
it is necessary to have a better
understanding when we're talking about
images or sound but really the second
difference the difference between
digital and analog is probably far more
important of the two
i haven't explicitly talked about the
difference between digital analog
even though that's really what we've
been doing these last two lectures the
electron images
and electron sound and so in this video
i really want to
explicitly talk about analog versus
digital
so analog refers to continuous signals
when we're looking at the real world
the real world is filled with continuous
quantities
in contrast what digital means is we're
storing information in discrete
quantities
and so really what digital images is all
about and what digital music
or digital sound is all about is taking
the real analog world
and converting it into these discrete
quantities which we can store inside the
computer
so there's always this process when we
want to move something into the computer
we have to take that real world analog
entity and all its glory
and somehow convert it to the digital
world
you know if we're looking at a picture
so here's a here's a photograph of
the red hoop fountain in front of green
library
you know let's say we're actually
standing there in front of the library
and the world with all its glory is out
there
and so we can ask questions like well
how many colors are there in the real
world
how many pixels are there in the real
world these questions don't make sense
the real world
does not have a discrete number of
colors it does not have discrete pixels
and so what happens when we take a
digital photograph is
we're converting it from the real world
into these discrete units that can be
stored inside of our computer
we're converting the real in the real
world
into individual pixels and for each of
these individual pixels
we're taking a look at the color and
we're saying hey you know i need to
convert that color
into the sequence of eight bits for red
eight bits for green and eight bits for
blue and so i'm digitizing the real
world
so that it can store it as discrete
quantities
inside the computer where i can start in
these individual bits
and bytes similarly when we're looking
at our music when stanford symphony
orchestra is playing
beethoven's fifth symphony out in front
of the classroom they are not generating
a stream
of numbers with forty four thousand one
hundred numbers
being generated per second and each
number being between
negative thirty two thousand seven
hundred sixty eight and positive thirty
two thousand seven hundred sixty seven
that's not what they're doing
they're generating a continuous analog
signal
and what we need to do when we store
that into our computer is
we need to convert that continuous
analog signal
into discrete digital quantities so we
can actually store
them in the bits and bytes in our
computer memory